everybody  asked me about and we almost blew up the  internet that night you gave me the  one-word answer first of all i thought  it was hilarious you know kevin uh there  was talk about you coming back for the  playoffs last year so you really just  been working on your game  trying to get back your timing and  conditioning really to be honest correct  yeah  it was hilarious i want to thank you for  a great television moment personally  see see when you when you asked me that  question well you didn't ask me a  question you just was like  you just made a statement and i was  thinking he's about to ask me a  follow-up question so i didn't want to  like go off rambling about something you  had another question so it was just like  it was just a miscommunication it made  for good tv for sure it made for great  tv